liberal universities don't know what a
woman is and now they're not sure what a
plagiarist is either Harvard's embattled
president Claudine gay getting caught in
a major plagiarism Scandal that's only
getting worse the New York Post claims
Harvard spent weeks secretly
investigating Gay's alleged academic
dishonesty but covered it up Harvard
even used an expensive Law Firm to
threaten the post when they started
asking questions and according to the
school's paper Gay's been copying and
pasting for a long long time check out
the meaty chunks of texts she lifted on
her dissertation look at those meaty
chunks one of many examples but
Harvard's already done its own sham
investigation and cleared gay Greg she's
fine it's just a bunch of meaty chunks
here's a question to blow leftwing mind
if it's racist to fire Dr Gay because
she happens to be black why is it not
racist to keep her employed because
she's black aren't they both racist
especially if she's obviously
incompetent she checked boxes but they
never checked her work for that reason
the problem with Dei and diversity hires
is they create a future problem in the
person you hire first you narrow the
field of applicants if you just decide a
whole group cannot be there you're going
to you're going to eliminate a lot of
very qualified people and then the
person you choose assumes they're set
for life because if you're hiring
someone to write a racial wrong
then fire them firing them erases the
so-called progress you just made and so
they replace they replace Merit which is
a scourge of whiteness with Dei which is
why there is no merit in Dei it's
meritless because the variables are only
identity markers and so you ex you lose
out on experience and competence and you
end up with you know KGB or or or kamla
Harris or Dr gay or the last Marvel
movie um now right now they're going to
redefine plagiarism cuz that's what they
do I don't know what they're going to
call it but I think it's going to be no
different than the smash and grab but of
words you know it'll be like you know
you can take up to a thousand words and
get away with it exactly so you can run
out of the you can take everything you
want from the encyclopedia Banica that's
an old reference and then run away and
they can't let go of this they got to
stick with her because then the whole
race the whole house of race cards
collapses yeah Dana they called it not
plagiarism but inappropriate citations
yeah it's like the shoplifting of words
will be behind the counter CVS in order
to say anything you're going to have to
go and like ask a staff member to unlock
the cabinet so you can make up some
words I was thinking that this is
reminds me of the co hypocrisy of some
of the governors remember we we had
Newsome going to The French Laundry
Whitmer uh flying when she wasn't
supposed to we had uh the mayor of DC
she was at a dance when you were supp
dancing at a wedding when you weren't
supposed to be and all of this was um
you all have to comply with the plag ISM
rules but I don't yeah because I'm Claud
gay and so right now you also have
somebody from in the NAACP said that
gays the attacks on gays Administration
is part of a white supremacist agenda
but last I checked the only one who got
fired so far is a white woman and also
you Harold brought up the other day the
example out in Stanford which was about
inappropriate citation he was clear to
any wrongdoing they still fired him so I
think a lot of this is just making
people realize that Harvard is going to
have to dumb down its requirements if
they're in order to keep her Jessica so
if you were uh the board chair of
Harvard and you just hire this woman I
believe this year and not only do you
find out she's a plagiarist but she
thinks screaming kill all Jews is fine
what would you
do I would really struggle with this on
the Free Speech level I mean people have
gone back and looked through the codes
of conduct especially the pen code
saying that actually this is a tricky
one but as Dana pointed out when you're
getting prepped by all these lawyers you
probably push back and say actually I'm
not saying that or it's time that we
re-evaluate the code because we know if
we had supplemented Jew for any other
protected group that would never stand
on any of these campuses right um the
plagiarism
issue is complicated and the Crimson
what the journalist the young journalist
that the Crimson did I think is great
and I think they do incredible work and
this has been the past few years when
you think about what went on at Stanford
that they took down a professor student
journalism is such an important asset he
was founded do not wrong but they still
fired him but yes that's the same ex
that was the one I was just talking
about was the same yeah sorry bad
example I guess um they said in the
Crimson that it showed that there were
violations under Harvard's current
policies around plagiarism and academic
Integrity so that implies current
standards versus old standards and I
know when I submitted my PhD there was
software that we put it through so that
and that's a new thing that you can do
that and it was one of the scariest sets
of weeks of my life thinking did I miss
something I hired someone as well paid
them out of pocket to check my PhD
because the last thing you want is
you're going before the committee and
they say you improperly cited this or
you lifted this and there is you know
not done to use the CVS joke but there
is a certain amount of text that you can
lift from other people where they say
this is understandable that it happens
because academic work is premised on the
work of those are some meaty chunks
Jessica I'm not saying put those meaty
chunks up on the screen the issue is if
right now Claudine gay would not be
awarded her PhD something needs to be
done about that but that doesn't mean
that when she did get her PhD or wrote
those articles that she violated
Harvard's policy I'm not so sure about
that okay I think the current policy old
policy doesn't allow mey chunks like
that uned look there are multiple
instances I don't know what what do they
come up with 20 something in 27 okay I
mean the woman livs for a living okay
she's like Joe Biden and plagiarism and
the amazing part of this is what the
left does is if they want to protect you
then what they do is they just change
the definition they change the law so
plagiarism isn't really what you think
it is you know if you miss a comma or
quote here or there it's no problem if
the laws don't work for you or people in
your tribe I always refer to it as a
tribe then we'll just change it but when
you dig deeper in this you find out that
they that Harvard cleared her of
breaching the standards and plagiarism
and it turns out that the guy who was
involved is a guy named Swain and when
the New York Post called Harvard and
they were looking into the allegations
of plagiarism by Claudine gay they
threatened them with a high-powered Law
Firm that with defamation if the post
printed anything about Claudine gay I
think they sent them like a 17-page
letter threatening them but this guy
Swain was part of the Biden Harris
transition team he was an aid to Hillary
Clinton okay and so for the left they
can't have anyone take out someone to
make it look like it's a success by
people on the right who believe in in in
the law and following the law so it this
is to me a tribal thing they don't care
they talk out of both sides of their
mouths and this is a woman who said you
know free speech is alive and well at
Harvard and then two days later shuts
down a conservative event I mean they
just they're not they're not fair about
it well if I was a Harvard student I'd
plagiarize all year what's stopping you
now all year long what's stopping you
now going back to get like an no just
let's just plagiarize all the
time why would I do that I have academic
honor from his shows hi everyone I'm
Brian kilme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now